Buonasera Prova a proporre un
ragionamento e una sintesi su una
questione che tocca molto la nostra
isola
la nostra comunità
che in altri tempi si usava il termine
questione meridionale io per la nostra
isola credo che sia corretto parlare di
questione energetica perché la questione
energetica per la nostra isola
rappresenta una precondizione per
avere presente soprattutto per generare
i
futuro Naturalmente la nostra isola non
non può ragionare di questioni
energetiche Se prova a farlo solo a casa
propria trovando le ragioni solo a casa
propria per le scelte le questioni
energetiche sono questioni
internazionali questioni che toccano
relazioni e rapporti che nascono spesso
in aree del mondo anche molto
distanti due dei temi che sono rimasti
molto molto vivi molto presenti nelle
discussioni su quali scelte energetiche
per le comunità più o meno ampie Eh come
possono essere le aree geografiche
l'Europa o gli stati l'Italia o aree
m periferiche Come vengono definite
quelle per esempio delle isole queste le
soluzioni A queste questioni Eh sono
trovano spesso dei fattori comuni quali
sono i due fattori comuni sui quali
volevo soffermarmi qua qualche qualche
minuto per individuare poi la soluzione
corretta o più Secondo me più corretta
possibile la decisione più appropriata
da prendere per dare un impostazione di
futuro alla questione energetica sarda
ma ci sono due punti fondamentali Il
primo è È nota la relazione che esiste
tra crescita economica e consumo
energetico
finora si è vista una relazione diretta
se si ha crescita economica è perché si
ha consumo energetico e senza consumo
energetico non si ha crescita economica
sono due fattori che vanno molto molto
in comune con una relazione diretta
naturalmente
ehm Oggi possiamo cominciare a
distinguere che questa relazione È molto
vera per i paesi che si chiamano in via
di sviluppo Cioè per sviluppare devo
continuare a crescere anche Nei consumi
energetici un po' meno vera per quelli
che sono già sviluppati perché la sfida
degli ultimi due decenni Soprattutto
l'ultimo decennio è fare quella
operazione che si chiama
disaccoppiare la crescita economica dal
consumo energetico
disaccoppiare vuol dire che si deve
cercare di avere economie o di stimolare
di sviluppare economie che per ogni
unità di crescita di per esempio del
prodotto interno lordo si usi sempre
meno energia Questo
naturalmente è È un processo in corso
che tocca tutto il mondo avanzato che
tocca l'Europa che tocca l'Italia e
naturalmente tocca anche la Sardegna il
miglioramento dell'efficienza nell'uso
finale dell'energia nella nell'uso
razionale dell'energia processi sempre
più efficienti ed efficaci consumi
sempre più responsabili portano verso
questa direzione in tutti e due i casi
comunque Dunque esiste una relazione
assolutamente diretta tra crescita
economica e adesso uso un termine un
pochino diverso disponibilità
energetica Se c'è quella forma e quella
quantità di energia È probabile che è
più probabile che si generi dello
sviluppo se non ci fosse è meno
probabile che si determinino certi tipi
di sviluppi il secondo punto il secondo
punto ha a che vedere con una
sensibilità che devo dire fino a 10 anni
fa trovava
molto meno Attenzione anche del mondo
scientifico o anche del
mondo
diciamo nella nella discussione anche
politica ed è il tema del consumo
ambientale quello più noto è quello di
riscaldamento del pianeta Ma insomma il
concetto è consumare risorse ambientale
cioè c'è sempre ormai una consapevolezza
scientifica ormai provata dimostrata è
anche una consapevolezza diciamo di
sensazione che tutti noi nel quotidiano
cominciamo a a a ad avere
che il consumo di energia è soprattutto
di fonti fossili è direttamente
collegato a una alterazione che può
essere anche molto drammatica misurata
nei tempi medi lunghi del nostro del
nostro del nostro ambiente e non tanto
l' del Campidano o l'ambiente dell'isola
di Sardegna o del Mediterraneo o
dell'Europa Ma l'ambiente in senso un
po' più vasto mondiale Tant'è vero che
le politiche da questo punto di vista
sono più politiche di continente
politiche di Vasta di vasta
portata credo che questo sia una una
cosa molto positiva
perché riduce le conflittualità tra
coloro che dicono che questa non è una
variabile da tenere in considerazione e
gli altri che
dicono ogni cosa che si
fa genera un grande pericolo Quindi è
bene non farla avere tutti un po' più di
consapevolezza è una cosa buona bene
questi due
fatti che appaiono così distanti dalla
Sardegna Io credo che debbano essere
tenuti in una considerazione molto più
alta molto più alta perché hanno
determinato in questi ultimi 30 anni e
non è a caso il termine 30 anni ma
rischiano di determinare per i prossimi
30 Forse anche 50 anni delle condizioni
davvero gravi e pesanti per la nostra
isola perché
questo perché la nostra isola è una
delle dei pochi luoghi d'Europa
dell'Europa avanzata che non dispone di
una fonte energetica di un vettore
energetico che per rispondere a quelle
due tematiche che ho posto prima è
considerato nel medio periodo 30-50 anni
essenziale ed è il gas
metano 30 anni fa forse anche qualcosa
di più si è sembrava fosse matura la
decisione di far arrivare il metano in
Sardegna poi Sembrava ancora più matura
15 anni fa quando si costituì anche un
consorzio che di Sardegna in Sardegna
doveva portare anche troppo di gas
metano il famoso consorzio galsi e
Oggi si è ancora lì a discutere e a
vedere che cosa se e come questa risorsa
energetica può essere disponibile per la
nostra
isola il momento io credo che sia
assolutamente da questo punto di vista
maturo e ha Dal mio punto di vista cerco
di argomentare in un minuto perché una
soluzione
strategica alla quale dalla quale non si
può Secondo me pres indere con un
processo decisionale che è pronto maturo
e che deve essere preso subito ed è che
la Sardegna deve essere collegata
attraverso una forma la più stabile la
meno diciamo così condizionabile
possibile da eventi futuri la nostra
economia è stata condizionata da eventi
esterni continuamente perché era
vulnerabile agli eventi esterni dai
eventi futuri esterni deve essere
collegata con il sistema dei delle
produzioni e dei consumi europei del gas
Perché se questo non si facesse Allora
noi abbiamo voglia di discutere delle
nostre specificità delle nostre
specialità della nostra perifericità ma
saremo sempre in una posizione di
svantaggio non avremmo possibilità di
utilizzare quella che l'Unione Europea
nella sua politica per i prossimi 40-50
anni a definire quella che è stata
definita la roadmap 2050 cioè come fare
in modo che nel 2050 l'economia
dell'Europa e quindi anche quella della
Sardegna
sia diciamo così
disaccoppiato dall'uso di fonti
inquinanti si stima che nel 2050
l'Europa e quindi anche la Sardegna
consumi il 65% della sua energia
deriverà che consumerà deriverà da fonti
alternative
direte Ma allora cosa c'entra il metano
con le fonti alternative ha una
relazione molto più diretta di quanto
non si pensi perché proprio il metano
sempre dall'Unione Europea in tutti i
suoi documenti è considerato lo
strumento fondamentale per cogliere
quegli obiettivi al
2050 cioè le comunità che avranno
disponibili questo vettore energetico
sono quelle che contribuiranno
parteciperanno E contribuiscono e
partecipano ne hanno anche un beneficio
Naturalmente devono essere in grado di
coglierlo questo beneficio allo sviluppo
del sistema
economico europeo Quindi io faccio il
sillogismo contrario e se non ce
l'abbiamo Se non ce l'abbiamo avremo un
elemento significativo di competitività
in meno è assolutamente essenziale che
però questa decisione si prenda subito
dal mio punto di vista è assolutamente
matura L'Italia ha lo Stato Italiano ha
e quindi anche la Sardegna ha a
disposizione uno strumento importante
come per esempio una società che ha come
finalità la costruzione di gasdotti per
collegare le varie aree di consumo con
le aree di produzione
dell'Europa direi del mondo anche ed è
Snam Rete Gas Snam Rete Gas ha questo
come compito quindi dal mio punto di
vista la la nostra regione deve fare
insieme con lo stato quello che serve
per fare in modo che si costruisca una
linea di collegamento tra il centro nord
della dell'Italia dove vi sono qualche
decina di migliaia di chilometri di tubi
che portano metano nei luoghi di consumo
con il nord Sardegna e poi una dorsale
che partendo dal nord Sardegna arrivi
fino al sud Anche perché l'isola nel
frattempo da 10 anni a questa
parte ha cominciato a realizzare i luogi
di consumo con i famosi bacini ma questi
luoi di consumo Oggi sono alimentati con
metano chi consuma scusate con GPL CH
consuma energia in quel luogo la paga
due volte di più lo ripeto due volte di
più che se non avesse consumato nello
stesso luogo per fare la stessa cosa
metano
perché dico indispensabile un
collegamento infrastrutturale di questa
natura
perché legarsi a una iniziativa magari
di un privato o anche di due privati in
Sardegna
che decidono di approvvigionare loro il
metano per noi
sardi non ci dà garanzia che questa
soluzione per i prossimi 30 40 forse
anche 50 anni Sia economicamente valida
per la nostra isola Noi abbiamo bisogno
di collegarci con i mercati mondiali che
rappresentano la miglior forma di
competitività per la disponibilità
energetica Naturalmente se vi fosse un
unico importatore e un unico
distributore questo non avviene Ma le
leggi economiche lo dicono non il fatto
che uno possa essere più buono o meno
buono Noi abbiamo bisogno di avere le
infrastrutture dei tubi che devono
essere che devono essere separate da chi
in giro per l'Europa può renderci
disponibile il metano che ci transita
dentro soltanto facendo sì che la nostra
isola si colleghi direttamente ai
sistemi di distribuzione più ampi questo
è possibile farlo le altre alternative
possono avere una valenza nell'immediato
forse ma rappresenterebbero un punto di
vulnerabilità davvero pesante nel lungo
nel lungo termine
naturalmente chiudo il ragionamento
naturalmente questa scelta che è una
scelta naturalmente parte è una scelta
politica è una scelta che ha anche una
valenza economica e di strategia
energetica
nazionale è una scelta che ha dei tempi
per potersi per potersi
realizzare nel frattempo ci possono
essere delle soluzioni che si possono
prendere alcuni imprenditori privati per
esempio stanno cominciando a costruirsi
piccoli impianti per portare gas
naturale sempre metano sostanzialmente
liquefatto lo portano liquefatto nel
loro stabilimento e lì lo evaporano si
dice rigas ificare Ma insomma significa
evaporare farlo passare dallo stato
liquido allo stato gassoso e lo
consumano se valeva 100 la differenza
di costo e quindi di convenienza che c'è
tra usare il metano e usare il GPL
naturalmente Qui se ne Recupera soltanto
una frazione se ne Recupera soltanto
magari 50 o 40 dipende dalla
installazione però è comunque un buon
passo avanti rappresenta nell'immediato
qualche cosa da fare non c'è dubbio ma
non può rappresentare la soluzione
strutturale per la nostra isola per i
prossimi per i prossimi 40-50 anni poi
quello che avverrà dai 50 anni in poi
tutti auspichiamo di poter vivere in un
mondo nel quale guardiamo il sole e ci
riscaldiamo aspettiamo che arrivi la
sera e Usiamo le frigorie per poterci
poi
riscaldare
raffreddare rinfrescare durante durante
il giorno che le nostre macchine
Circolino facilmente senza utilizzare
fonti fossili che insomma viviamo in un
mondo bello e diverso ma nel frattempo
noi abbiamo l'onere di accompagnare le
nostre comunità e la
nostra necessità di esistere in senso
economico non soltanto in senso
culturale di esistere nei prossimi 40-50
anni Questo è un mio pensiero Questa è
una
mia non solo mia naturalmente ci sono
tanti altri che forse che la pensano
così ma la differenza Secondo me è che
questa decisione va presa
oggi
Grazie Y